[Applaudissements]
les célébrations du jubilé de la reine
viennent à peine de se terminer
rapidement le premier ministre
britannique est rattrapé par la réalité
confronté à un vote de confiance boris
johnson a tenté toute la journée de
convaincre ses députés de ne pas
l'abandonner résultat le premier
ministre conserve son poste
mais derrière cette victoire apparente
un fort mécontentement
148,10 3 159 députés conservateurs ont
exigé son départ à l'origine des
frustrations des fêtes organisée à la
résidence officielle dans nine street
alors que le pays était en confinement
présent à certains de ces événements
boris johnson a même reçu une amende de
la part de la police
signe de l'insatisfaction à son endroit
le premier ministre a même été hué en se
rendant à une cérémonie religieuse
organisée dans le cadre du jubilé de la
reine
c'était un moment déterminant 17
londonienne
cet autre reproche au premier ministre
de mentir constamment des critiques
compte entendu des élus conservateurs à
travers le pays
il pense par exemple que boris johnson
aurait dû démissionner dès le mois de
janvier est le premier ministre a aussi
de nombreux défenseurs
comme la ministre de la culture qui
vante sa gestion de briques site et de
la campagne de vaccination
le premier ministre veut maintenant que
son parti passe à autre chose et cessent
de s'entre déchirer ah non
mais pour l'opposition officielle le mal
est déjà fait les conservateurs sont
divisés
s'il conserve son poste boris johnson
ressort de ce vote affaibli avant de
demander à l'électorat de lui faire de
nouveau confiance il devra commencer par
convaincre les membres de son propre
parti
raphaël boris johnson a donc réussi à
sauver son poste mais son parti est loin
d'être unis alors qu'est ce qu'il attend
maintenant en tout cas boris johnson ne
pourra pas faire l'objet d'un autre vote
de confiance jugeant revenante ses
propres rangs pour au moins un an c'est
ce que prévoient les règles du parti
conservateur mais ça ne veut pas dire
que la pression ne va pas cessé de
s'accentuer sur le premier ministre
britannique d'abord il y aura une
épreuve électorale il ya des élections
partielles qui sont prévues à la fin du
mois dans deux circonscriptions en
angleterre deux sièges conservateurs
sont en jeu ici on se fie aux sondages
en tout cas pour l'une de ces deux
circonscriptions le parti conservateur
est en danger donc ça pour ajouter de la
pression sur le premier ministre si son
parti perd ces élections et puis on en
revient aussi céline à ce scandale
entourant les fêtes à downing street
j'ai passé plusieurs jours au cours de
la dernière semaine ici au royaume uni
notamment pendant le jubilé de la reine
et même pendant ses activités lorsqu'on
parlait à des électeurs britanniques
c'est un sujet qui revenait donc est ce
que parce que ce vote de confiance est
chose du passé les électeurs cesseront
de parler de cet enjeu qui a nui à
l'image de boris johnson 10 est loin
d'être certain le premier ministre veut
tourner la page donc mais ce n'est pas
clair qu'il réussira à le faire si
facilement oui ce n'est peut-être pas
fini merci beaucoup raphaël